may ask why did you both stop working at
SeaWorld for me I stopped working at
SeaWorld because I felt like I could do
more for the animals with an advanced
degree so I was thinking about either
going back to school to get my
veterinary degree or maybe going to
school to get an architectural or design
degree so I could design better habitats
for the whales I didn't end up doing it
but that was my thoughts like how I
could make their lives better yeah I
love SeaWorld really not knowing what I
wanted to do next I had an opportunity
to travel and I knew that I had seen
enough things there that had made me
uncomfortable along the way that it
wasn't a path I wanted to stay on but I
can't say that I knew that I was going
to what I was going to be moving on to
at that point
you